[Music]
when you're wanting to do something out
of the box there's always going to be
opposition from a society where parents
want you to subscribe to certain things
as long as you are doing the thing that
other people want you to do with your
career with your life with your business
you will lose you got to think outside
the box mm-hmm because that's the only
way you're gonna get out were you
trapped in the trap you really mentally
trapped in the trap rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's up Philippe
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and i believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
break the mold over to you go go go Paul
bass when you're wanting to do something
out of the box there's always going to
be opposition from a society where
parents want you to subscribe to a
certain things a settled job a settled
life in terms of family and your
thinking completely out of the box as
soon as you want to do something out of
the box you're going to have to face
challenges from the family side after a
while however when my family saw where I
was reaching how I was impacting
people's lives however how I was really
able to make a difference in the world
they accepted it very well and I feel in
terms of coping up with the challenges
of how my friends have moved on the
industry I think it's a question of
self-discovery I hate I hate being a
part of a mold that the world created
for me I don't want to subscribe to the
mold that the world creates for you I
don't want to live a life in a paradigm
that the world is created for me I want
to discover my own mold I want to have a
paradigm that I have invented you know
only when you discover yourself only
when you live a life for what you are
free
is when you feel happy satisfied not
just happy and satisfied you're super
effective even in the corporate world
today
loads of people I just living in life
which they are not created for because
it pays the bucks and why do they need
the Box to pay the taxes to pay the
pills bills to pay the marketers but
they're not living a life of what they
are created for so it's basically kind
of you know fitting in just because it
pays you but I decided I don't want to
fit in so when I saw others moving on my
friends my colleagues moving on high up
I really did not feel insecure at all
because I didn't want to fit in to be
someone else I wanted to find myself
discover myself there's as soon as you
of successful in your self-discovery man
you are effective and completely
satisfied as long as you live in your
parents version of your life you're
gonna lose as long as you are doing the
thing that other people want you to do
with your career with your life with
your business you will lose everybody
has an opinion on what you should do the
parents your guidance counselor your
friends your aunt's your uncle's your
grandparents everybody around you has an
opinion of what you should do and until
you understand for yourself and you take
a stand and say this is what I'm trying
to do then you'll allow people to walk
all over you and you'll never be happy
making somebody else happy doing this
thing because you want your parents to
love you and be happy means you will
never be happy for yourself now
fortunately for me my parents always
supported me in what I wanted to do the
biggest hater that I had in building
this business was the guy who was close
to me a guy who gave me some advice was
helping me on my path and he became the
little man that's in the book for your
one word I had made this great video
that I was so proud of I'm Emma I made
my first believe video it was a
six-and-a-half minute video
I loved it we put a lot of effort into
it more effort than any video that I've
ever done before it was six and a half
minutes he saw I showed it to him
because it's in the industry and he said
it was too long it wasn't good I didn't
understand how the internet worked all
of this super strong negativity that an
older version of me might have said huh
maybe we should make changes maybe we
should edit it maybe he's right he knows
what he's talking about he's in this
business maybe I should listen to him
but for whatever reason
you know had enough confidence in myself
and my plan to say you know what I can
deal with it not working but I can't
deal with not knowing I had to least try
I have to try I loved it I was super
proud of what I made I loved it
what if nobody else liked it that's okay
I need to put it up just to see I'm
happy to be proved wrong
and so we put it up and ended up being
my best video on the channel at the time
by a huge mark but even if it didn't
work out it's still worth it to do it
just to know because to play small
because if somebody else's opinion your
expectation is never the right move okay
great and I was how do you how do you do
that how do you have the conversation
how do you deal with these parents we
keep telling you you're never gonna win
down this path and go do something else
I got three pieces of advice for you
number one is have empathy understand
that your parents love you your parents
love you most parents love their kids
there might be some that are just wild
and crazy and have some kind of disease
but but most parents love their kids
they love you they want you to win the
empathy is just understanding that
you're growing up in a different world
than what they understand the
opportunities available for you we're
not available to them did not exist the
things that you can now do with your
life as a young person compared to your
parents what was available to them at
the same age is it's it's a totally
different world it's mind-boggling ly
different and so having some empathy to
understand that one they love you
two they want you two to win they want
you to have success they want you to be
happy they're just seeing it through
their world they're seeing it through
their lens because for them growing up
it was you know get a job get married
saying the same job forever have a bunch
of kids like this is the typical plan
this is how you win and because you're
not doing it they're gonna see you as
being a failure they're gonna see you as
not being happy and so just
understanding that if you go into a
conversation understand this is how they
think and the why behind they think
besides don't come to the conversations
thinking well they're so close-minded I
never support me and they hate me and
they won't let me win they won't let me
do my thing if that's the approach that
you go into a conversation everybody
loses as soon as you go on the offense
and start then now
the other person and judging them you
lose the it's so hard for anybody to be
taken in all of that crap from somebody
else and then stay calm and say I
understand where you're coming from
right so don't expect your parents to
have that kind of empathy and
understanding for you you do it first
understand where they're coming from
step two is have a real conversation
most conversations will go like what I
just demoed most conversations will go
like you never support me you don't
understand me I'm trying to do this you
hate me you're the worst parents ever I
don't know why you won't appreciate what
I'm trying to do and you have a tone you
have anger you're frustrated you're
judging you're blaming and so what are
they gonna do as a response if somebody
came at you with that what would you do
as a response the defense's come up high
the walls come up high and they're gonna
fight back we're at the core you both
want the same thing you both want love
you both want happiness for each other
but just the way you express is
differently so try this as an approach
if you approach them and say hey mom and
dad this is a dream of mine I understand
that you want me to be happy you want me
to be successful you want me to do you
proud you want me to have you know make
my mark in the world this might be the
path for me to do it it may not be it
may not be the path I might fail I might
be you know everything might crash and
burn all of all of my dreams just may
never be realized I can deal with that
failure but what I can't deal with is
not knowing I don't want to be 50 years
old 75 years old a hundred years old
looking back on my life at this moment
in saying I wish that I had tried it I
don't want to live the rest of my life
with regret it may work out it may be
great
the odds are actually saying that it
won't and I might fail and I probably
will fail I can deal with that I can
accept it because I gave it my shot and
I know I may end up having to go and you
know sleep on the couch just to get by
as I pick myself back up and I hope that
it could be your couch because I would
really love and appreciate your support
with on my journey I think if you
brought it like that I think if you
showed them how much you love them and
care about them how much you understand
where they're coming from
what you are asking for their support I
think for most people that shifts a
conversation I think it's really hard to
see your kid pour their heart out and
then slam them back down and they may
they may they may sign me down and at
that point you decide at what point do
you take accountability for your life
but I I have a funny feeling for a lot
of you your parents will be a lot more
supportive and a lot more understanding
because you took that first bold step
and then number three is just take
action the thing you want to do start
finding a way to do it even part-time
even on the side go start do it do it do
it do it find the smallest possible way
to get started great example in this age
group I think about is Michael Dell who
he wanted to start his computer company
and he started while he was at
university he was studying to be a
doctor going to med school and he was
having success while still studying and
doing his thing on the side and then he
convinced his parents to take the summer
off and instead of going to work at some
job that they wanted him to work at he
said give me Heath give me the summer
give me the summer let me work on this
thing and if it does well it'll take off
and if it fails we'll go back to being a
med school student it didn't fail it did
well he ended up you know leaving med
school and building his company but the
key part was he started he started he
was going to school he was doing his
thing and he started his business on the
side you don't need to quit everything
you're doing in order to start down the
path that you want to go down if you
want to be a youtuber to start making
videos you don't need your entire day
free to make videos you have time you
can do it whatever the thing is that you
want to do do it right now in your part
time and then find every opportunity to
try to hack it to do more so Michael
Dell was the summer right some are gonna
go full-time it doesn't work we'll go
back to my job right summer go back do
your thing full-time see how much
progress you can make more important
than even the results is more like did
you is this the thing like as you're
doing it more and more if you're doing
every day for the summer you do it every
day for 3-4 months it's like yes this is
absolutely the thing I'm so in love with
this thing this has to be my path it
gives you more certainty that even if
you don't get the results but even if
you don't get to support from your
parents and your family that you have to
go off and do that thing where if it's
only a dream if it's only idea you never
actually take any kind of action on it
you never have the certainty you never
chase it
so whatever the thing is start right now
some part-time small way every single
day half an hour a day and now
or day moving that idea that project of
ears forward now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know what is the
toughest conversation topic that you've
ever had to have with somebody in your
family I'm really curious to know leave
it in the comments below thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
don't let expertise silence you work to
find new solutions to old problems think
outside of the parameters that restrict
other people's thoughts just because
you're a novice on the job just because
you haven't faced the same challenges
just because you haven't climbed the
same cliffs doesn't mean that you can't
contribute to solutions in very
significant ways when you're chided for
your naivete and you will be remind your
critics that an amateur built the art
experts built the Titanic statistic said
if I did that and I stopped going to
school and that's all I did was hanging
a hood that I wasn't gonna be here today
mmm-hmm but that's why I still hang with
the same people that I was with back in
the hood and I changed my mentality I
don't think the same way I was when I
was there open my mind up I thought
broader I thought outside of my horizons
it like you got to think outside the box
mm-hmm because that's the only way
you're gonna get out when you trapped in
the shop you really mentally trapped in
the trap and it's me me like man I want
to make sure my people just know that
that's just not the end of your life
like if somebody tell you these
statistics that's not true
you're gonna fight statistics and go to
the next level like so chicks you said I
wouldn't even be here talking to you
right now mm-hmm
if I would have listened to them and
tell them how my life would have been
they say one out of ten people they're
gonna be like this or nine out of ten
black males if they do this live this
way they're gonna do this you know I'm
saying there's no way around it they
gonna tell you is no way around so if
you in the hood right now you're
standing on a block every day then
police does rhyme by that old lady
that's looking at you that's calling the
police on you the people who Ryan by
just looking at you like lane nothing
your pants sagging I think you ain't
gonna never be nothing they think you're
gonna be like that for the rest of your
life like who is the person to tell you
that you're gonna be standing on this
block all your life supposed to be a
point in your life where you only be
here for you get yourself a year to you
from here you don't do no good for you
to be here all your life and you
spending majority of your life
22 hours I showed eight trying to prove
you the heart is in the hood
you come from that you was born in as
you when you came home from the hospital
you went it's gonna hurt you know I'm
saying so you don't live your whole life
this way for all your life you deserve
to live in a different neighborhood to
better yourself for 3-4 years out of
your own life when you've been living
this way probably some dudes been living
that way for 20 years 23 years been in
the distance they came home from from
the house built and they still trying to
prove to the hood how hard they is in
the end I'm not making it because they
didn't prove today itself you gotta
prove to yourself that you want more
than wist ik world domination
honey empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video